hi i'm darren barnett i'm maitreya
ramakrishnan i'm jaren lewison and we're
here with buzzfeed to find out how well
we know each other
[Music]
how many of these things do you know
about your co-stars their birthday i
know both of their birthdays i know both
of their birthdays should we say them
darren's dressed
i don't know what you know his birthday
he doesn't know my birthday okay i don't
love my birthday so to be fair like i
give you a pass for that i don't
publicize my birthday she just loves my
birthday i love your birthday so that
doesn't count i'll give you a clue
mine's in the same month as hers oh okay
uh december 28th from thursday lower oh
december 13th close that's close
fourteenth
ninth runway ninth she's december 9th
darren's is april 27th which is also the
first release date of season one which
is so easy to remember please remember
yes i will i will never forget yeah
that's crazy i always remember their
middle name she doesn't have one
yeah you don't have one i don't know
is your name robert
not even close to be fair i don't know
darren's either you don't yeah
all right i have no idea yours starts
with an end yeah what is your story
matthew close no no
no what is your start with c either
colin
yeah there you go okay mine's a little
more obscure not like super but
mickey mouse yes oh hi everybody it's me
not so good one it's miles sharon miles
i'm gonna say guys i'm doing pretty good
i got i'm two for two yeah okay well you
guessed a couple of scenes uh their
favorite snack at crafty i'm gonna go
jaron with the green apple and peanut
butter yes
that's absolutely correct i'm gonna go
with the other choice though of the
double chocolate like
muffin yeah i love those you like those
yeah you sometimes feel guilty getting
them yes that's and i always encourage
you yeah my tree i i would
i don't know if it really counts but i
think it's more of like a drink
yes i do have a drink there's a snack
there's a snack that i like here is a
treat that i like
you know this oh wait wait wait wait
wait juice
him juice okay that's the drink that's
the drink there's a drink called pimp
juice that's like a thing i don't even
know what it is it's good they make it
for me though it is great it has
pineapple juice somewhere there but no
you know this i'm gonna say a chocolate
a chocolate it's a kind of chocolate
um
is it peanut m ms i hate peanut butter
what are they what is it it's a white
chocolate lendore
i didn't not have gotten that sorry it
was like sneaking no
maybe but i didn't register that one
okay i'm sorry i don't get the points
for that fine
you don't really get much
yeah you don't you like coffee and you
don't like
snacks you don't i don't know you don't
snack on a snack no you're not yeah we
get one of two do we check that off or
no you need help oh have we been
checking them off yeah you check out the
ones you got rice your favorite scene
ever to film and never have i ever
that's tough ever i don't even think i
know that about myself i don't either
did you say you solidly have fun i'm
also one of my favorites to watch it's
the first time we kiss in the car i just
love the candidates you see how we're
supposed to guess that though he's like
oh
i like that too it was good it was
iconic i will say though i think our
window scene trumps it yeah
yeah
i was like this is it that's my favorite
daxton moment
yeah what about you do you know one that
you like i feel like the pickle rick
scene was yes and it also like became
such a meme and a joke on set that like
yeah he just has never died i don't know
darren our scene in in season three is
one of my favorites yeah me too the
hospital that's one of my favorites yes
i will always just be proud of the
last therapy scene in season two i like
the one where i tell nalani i wish she
was the one that died that night that
one i was very proud of myself can i
help you or something because it's just
killing me you haven't had eyelashes
make a wish
the first time you met let's all check
that off yeah we all remember that yes i
got it i got us all in trouble we were
on set and they were like you can do
whatever you want and you took that
literally and we all to be fair i met
you before that that's true that is true
when we were doing our screen test which
is like our final auditions darren and i
thought that each other was auditioning
for the other person's role i didn't i
thought that he was auditioning for ben
and i was like this guy's way too hunky
like
competition i did not like him i tried
to talk to him he didn't want to talk i
don't like talking in the audition room
he was a talker i was like hey man how
you doing he was just like yeah you are
the competition don't do that but and
now i love him i was just happy to be
there yeah
spunky i love you too i love you okay
okay their favorite mini kaling project
other than never have i ever
the movie that they'll never stop
quoting
both of you guys constantly
whenever you're together
forget about it
i don't know what is that i mean pick
pick them up
yeah it's just generic okay but then if
you can't figure it out
forget about it
i don't know that my tree quotes movies
no she wants the office
all the time the thing they can't live
without in their dressing room i'm going
to say for jaron jaron is like me where
we
it it the dressing room ends the same
way it starts we don't do pretty much
anything with it but i feel like my
train needs pillows on her couch oh yeah
yeah
the lights and the pine cones
yeah
it's like a nice little shopping with my
trailer i like decorating it i will say
i guess one thing you couldn't live
without in your trailer before back way
when would be your laptop
yeah that's a good one when i was in
school that's true yeah i was like doing
classes in between like at lunch and
stuff yeah so i needed my laptop and
like wi-fi that's a good answer i didn't
even think about that their pet peeve
i'm gonna say my tray i definitely think
it is being talked down to she does not
like that no
i don't talk to earlier i have another
pet peeve though i think when other
people are mistreated that really
bothers you as well well that's just
injustice and that's just not right
that's just like morley
my real top feed is uh baby voices
i
hate hearing people do baby voices like
in a relationship it's so yes it's gross
it is so disgusting it's so hard stop
that
something they've definitely never ever
done before oh you guys should know mine
it's my go-to never have i ever i always
use this in interviews like i am
yeah yeah yeah well that's about to be
broken you're about to take a new one
it's about time to swim i'm gonna learn
all right and if i don't if i have i
don't pick it up when i go for classes
i'm gonna come to you jiren there's a
lot of things you haven't done but like
the one thing that like i won't do no
there's a lot that come on like one of
my fears i know you'd never go on a
roller coaster with me no like bigger
than that not not even with you just in
general with anybody
you don't like heights
so you won't go into the empire's date
building with me that's close but no
cigar i will never skydive everyone got
jumping out of a plane okay well i went
with height things i've asked for roller
coasters amusement parks i've asked for
a pair of date building roller coasters
can you just shoot though you're okay to
go on another
no i just don't want to i don't want six
flags down i don't want to go
maybe at disneyland i'll go on
disneyland that rollercoaster okay
there's a celeb idol growing up i'm
going to pick you carrie yeah definitely
wow
definitely i'm going to pick heath
ledger for you because i know
yeah
but that was also a great answer he is
like my favorite performance by an actor
in a specific project but robin williams
is like my favorite actor in general
what about me i got both of yours come
on um steve
steve carell yeah i've heard you say
that before
i really look up to steve carrell thank
you
so much
wait i honestly just started checking
everything guys i mean i know i got it
i'm trying to just like i'm like oh we
finished that question not eight out of
11. i got nine and up get eleven out of
them yeah i think i didn't know i think
i just didn't check it i don't know if i
actually got a point is since we were
experts point is we love each other we
love each other i do love them i love
them a lot
yeah that was a really good one i
couldn't really do anything
we love each other
thanks buzzfeed
make sure to watch never have i ever on
netflix season three